sometimes it's just fun to smash the
toys together so welcome to council of
geeks my name is Daniel Wayne joined
this time by Ryan Daley looking like
that for some reason pay the twenty new
subscribers you get from this video that
you're going to thank me for this one
fair enough I'll take what I can get so
we're doing something different this
time kind of a little bit as an
experiment so we're not going to talk
about news we're not going to talk about
you know projected films we're not going
to talk about anything that's happened
what we're going to do is dead is just
kind of go nuts and talk about
ridiculous mashups of universes
universes universes of movies of
whatever and not ones that have actually
been done but just ones that we thought
they were like that might be fun and not
a lot of restriction in terms of mixing
genres or anything else we're just it
was kind of whatever you feel like the
one thing that I did ask where I not to
bring the table was just mixing up you
know a Marvel property a DC property
because that's that's the easy go-to
stuff and most of its been done because
those two have done crossovers at some
point so um I Ryan you have to for now
and for now if something strikes me in
that way I know and I always kind of
thought of making one as you were doing
the intro so alright okay I have five
but I'm going to assume that might have
probably less thought out than yours
so I'll kick off because I've got more
of these alright so I'm actually going
to start with the one that was sort of
my initial oh they could just do that as
sort of my thing in my head is like in
my ideal world you wouldn't go into any
of these things knowing that these
things were going to crossover you would
go in maybe it was going to be whatever
the more predominant of the worlds is
and then you realize that it goes along
that the other thing is come in yeah so
Indiana Jones now this could be what
Harrison Ford is cooking with whoever
they inevitably get for the reboot
whatever but Harrison Ford he is in a
castle just now this place is
down it was a little isma'il often the
mountains it was way out of the way it
took him a lot of work to get there
somehow he's got you know he's got his
usual kid he's got the Whitman I've got
whatever but he's also you know taking
you know taking notes that he's kind of
he seems to be doing a little bit more
of what a normal archaeologist would do
so you know maybe this is his idea of a
vacation you know because it's it's it's
not supposed to be massively daily buzz
I know okay and he's getting the sense
that this thing is this place is older
than it's supposed to be
things are a little off many Suns coming
across some some classic ancient indeed
guest traps all over she gets around and
eventually he gets down to the basement
there wood coffin and the coffin the lid
slides off and Indy now has to deal with
the fact that he is stumbled into
Dracula's - equipment and so we have we
have Indiana Jones vs Dracula basically
set off because these archaeologists he
was Skokie was scoping out this this
castle that seemed that nobody seemed to
have gone near for a long time and now
he's got to deal with that yeah so I
love the idea I do I think it I think
it's brilliant the one thing that I have
mixed feelings about this is the
premises of the thing is our friend Rob
Kelly's 8 Kilroy comic webcomic he
created is essentially it archeology a a
pope adventure in the end Jones type of
character reverses vampires and monsters
so no the fact that you came up with an
Avenger it's a really good idea now I
would look around to have to be able to
sell his idea and have like his IP
become like a you know billion dollar
windfall idea because then I'll just
ride on his coattails and live off of
him like in Entourage or something else
that's how I pictured it you know your
turtle I hope you realize that or Johnny
or does it's is they're all the same but
yeah what so I liked it but at the same
time just being named recognition all
but to establish I
you mentioned Indiana Jones meets a
tarantula I really want to see that yes
that's a great idea
goodbye the iine that would just be a
lot and also it there is it is a very
organic idea where you just look yet
they play into each others realize just
yeah that's totally bad indiana jones
will discover through the natural course
of his thing it's not a dramatic leap in
genre or tone it is i mean the man's
dealt with aliens at this one is dracula
really they're happy valley premiere
right so no i love it so that sort of my
starting one so the first one that I
thought of and I had this idea for years
and every time I try to pitch it
somebody laughs at me so what will
receive that only just run alright and
picking up another kind of classic
monster character and this one the
monster Frankenstein okay
in the novel Mary Shelley's Frankenstein
you know where the monster ends up by
the end of the story
it's either the Arctic or the Antarctic
it is the art way up in the North Pole
and presumably dies but it's a little
bit end video sometimes that you're
lucky spot so in the grand mythos of
established fictional characters who
else do we know there's up in the North
Pole in the Arctic if you say the
fortress of solitude is not mean for man
okay I'm not okay
oh I'll send you have another jolly man
in the red oh yeah I can find sources
that say get applauded so now tons of
ways you can go with this you can go
very kid-friendly it's just a silly
little much other story about Santa
Claus whatever in fact it's either you
can do something like the opening of the
movie Scrooged with Lee Majors in the
head of the reindeer died where you
basically have Frankenstein assaulting
these elves and everything and I just
become like this horror story a survival
thing where it comes out with Frank
science and it falls just sliding at the
end of it on top of the slave I'll hang
over the side or something like that
what however way you want to play it
they're both based in the North Pole I
want to see that mashup Frankenstein and
Santa Claus I by me by the end I want it
to be a knockdown drag
oh yeah
you want to start whimsical or qgm
that's fine by the end I want I want the
gloves all I wanted I say is basically I
want like the Santa that we saw fight
Lobo I want to have kind of Santa by the
end
stern up as a mr. with something is
preying on the reindeer somebody needing
the reins here and haunting them down or
whatever and you know Santa in like some
of these like elf Suicide Squad is going
up this could be that now is Oh what if
the monster like took over the toy
making factory and started recalling the
elves together to try and make like
little minions
oh but as hard as I laughed at it
I actually I actually think that would
be very cool I like that so try that
what what am I gonna do next oh yeah
I was kind of saying this might be my
most ridiculous but I think I might be
saying that baby but that's what's
pretty nuts okay so this would be my
follow-up to frozen
okay so we're dealing with a you know
our initial sort of core characters
Queen also who you know has the ice
powers for sister Anna
you know the Olaf the little snowman
maybe throw Chris off in there I don't
know it doesn't matter but um so Olaf is
going to kick this off because he's the
most innocent kind of bumbling character
he can get them into situations easily
enough and it can just start very basic
because he eats his a fun-loving little
so man he does that so something as
simple as they're just playing hide and
seek and he goes and he hides in in a
part of the castle and a piece of
furniture that nobody seems so noticed
before and the others go looking for gas
and found him in a while and when they
find this things like what is it I'll
offer you in there they go through and
now they're in Narnia okay
and so I can't I I go back and forth on
the details of this but I can't decide
if I want advice I would have this
interrupts the events of the lion which
in the wardrobe where basically
you end up with Elsa versus the white
clean or if it's set way after all that
stuff and then Elsa is mistaken for thee
like selected for the white white which
reincarnated yeah and then it becomes
frozen versus Narnia but those did there
was just something about about the idea
of Elsa stumbling into the Narnia did
you bring the others along with her that
just got to make me go and why not you
could almost you could almost marry
those two different options by having
some sort of comical thing where her
appearance she accidentally kills the
White Queen and then basically just
stumbles into her same position that and
it becomes essentially the same conflict
the story continues throughout but just
what the slave variation of Elsa doesn't
really understand why these events are
happening around her why everybody hates
herbalizer methuselah she sees his
massive line that that that thing she's
evil is you thought well I'm going to
take him down and everyone's a mask
against reaching up and under yes you
know he really gets her for some unknown
reason again they're grinding out loud
it would be for her so I like that so
cool oh alright so you want to do
another do you want to go with my next
one okay um and without with paying too
much of a picture we start off with
Tarzan okay and it's Tarzan lord of the
jungle doing his kind of Tarzan shtick
and something is hunting the animals
around his kingdom around his world all
right
and hunting them in a very particular
way he starts finding you know with
baboon friends or whatever kind of like
animal in the jungle strung up overhead
skin okay you can already tell her I'm
going it's Tarzan versus the predator
now the way that I was sort of
distinguishes because it's visually it
could play out very much like the first
predator movie or does it have in
Thailand and I
subsequent ones where it's all sort of
in the jungle in that environment what I
would try to do to be a little different
is still set this in the 1800's and I
saw or knows wherever but kind of even
though it doesn't make sense because
it's an alien with alien technology sort
of bring the predator back that level
and make it a little bit more steampunk
where it doesn't have the laser cannons
where is our pivot arsenal is a little
bit more primitive slightly like it
might actually have like a version of a
bow and arrow instead of instead of like
the shoulder cannon okay and they even
just look a little bit different so it
seems a little bit more primitive so
steampunky versus is sort of just kind
of more grounded down to earth but
eventually it's going to come very much
like the end of predator where you got
the shortlist hunk guy fighting the
predator but he also has but the eight
side his side lit candle yeah so yeah so
that makes my Tarzan versus the
president I I'm not sure I have anything
bad guy because yeah that just works
with the natural side and that's
actually the same because I have a
predator match okay which thankfully
plays out somewhat somewhat different
okay so this would be a case where this
would be kind of leaping off from the
first one a little bit but the the
predator they're not they're not quite
the outright villains of the store okay
so this is the case where the government
knows about that mm-hmm and they know
it's not worth the effort to try and
stop them because if they ever decided
that we were getting in their way what
they do too much they could effectively
just wipe us out so there's kind of been
an agreement reached where there is
basically kind of there's this kind of a
game park okay which is barn a little
bit of you know from predators where
they have like overlaying of them but
this is kind of watch over and maintain
and you know a guard around the edges
and overall monitored by the men in
black okay so what you would have is
you'd have the men in black not only
keeping you other humans from stumbling
onto this thing but also trying to make
sure that the Predators stay within the
board
where they're supposed to be hunting and
you can actually end up with a bit of a
bit of a wacky cop scenario where you
know there's there's one predator who
you just keep keep stumbling outside the
borders like weak and then you just
gotta wrangle him back because because
he's ego he saw a bull on somebody terms
I knew I'm going to get that no no no
get back here so then you know they're
still killing machines but if you can
bring just a men and black level of we
just got a wrangle these things because
they were here we have to deal with them
yeah and great it's anime almost they
always have to show you like the way you
you imagine is the native guides deal
with the rich dentist who go on safari
in Africa is like oh these guys again ok
let's set you up for the kill here there
it is go ahead and then that kind of
resigned
it's just what we have to do nature do
it in which we just kind of what I
always liked about men and black and
head at least at first one because they
got very obsessed about those those
juices every character and engrave their
chemistry was for me the hook was always
yeah it's aliens this this is our daily
grind this is just what we do I like it
okay yeah and I'm still trying to think
about like flashing kinda like convince
people that they didn't see that wasn't
a like no that was a cosplay I'll do
another one so okay this is one that I
actually think I've even seen fan
theories for this mashup before but I'm
going to go for anyway so mad max you
have Max Rockatansky out in the waste
just as he tends to be because that's
what else is maximum dude is going to
wander the way still he comes and just
stumbled into something that he wish he
has know tumbled into yes Billy
accidentally trips over the block yeah
that's that's that so he runs into you
know a typical mad neck scenario there
so people just trying to make it and
there's some bandits giving them trouble
but there's also this big ass
all that they're all kind of camped out
in front of and they all seem to kind of
want to get in but not really notice on
the other side of this thing and but
that's that invention the bandit
situation is so bad that Max realizes
that he and these people need to try and
get on to the other side of that wall so
they're looking out for any way in I
haven't got the details of exactly how
they get in but eventually they do get
on the other side of this wall and they
find themselves inside megacity one okay
which means that they are now under the
under the they fall under the
jurisdiction of one judge dredd yeah and
so now you got Dredd who from his
perspective is dealing with the the
mutants that live outside in the wait
have infiltrated his city yeah
and so now you have Mad Max versus Judge
Dredd I like I actually I had sort of
like a Judge Dredd idea was percolating
in my head - and I was trying to think
of something and I just kept coming up
with Judge Dredd and Robo Cop which a
Dark Horse Comics might have done that
all rain might if they might end up
Roman Coppola wanna but I also kind of
thought I was like those are two similar
ideas they're both law enforcement are
both stoic like kind of a motion with
people with the guns medicine so uh I
didn't think judges were look I didn't
think it gave you anything that the
other one didn't give you individually
was just random Mad Max be hella be a
fun team up if anything does he just
read on his motorcycle in the in the
math and going over next to mad Max's
car yes I mean no that I mean eventually
if you feel like having them team up you
can have the bandits outside manage to
follow them in and so that I mean that
they're just record shop and they team
up against then you could go that way
but I just I it just seems like a
natural fit
because Dredd has all has all the world
of Judge Dredd as always we've got the
mega cities and out there's the waste
we don't go out there and what's Mad Max
it's a wasteland
side it doesn't feel like that big of
lead to just say yeah on either side of
this wall take your dystopia okay I
think I was all right
so did you did you have any other
narrative of it and so high dose denies
one else's something okay this one this
one's my finality this is my big one
okay so the ring now they tried to bring
this back because I actually I had to
double check to be sure the movie had
actually come out yeah I remember I was
talking about the swap and it hid God
nobody noticed nobody cared it made no
money franchise is dead so you've got
your typical ring setup and now
unfortunately part of the reason the
sequels didn't work is because as end up
being is the situation with almost every
would be horror franchise eventually all
you're doing is recycling to set up with
a new group of fodder and you're going
to you are going to start from that
place where you know it's the haunted
video I didn't see rings again nobody
did so I don't know how the curtains
actually working this place whether it's
online or out so but however it's
getting spread so somebody has seen it
they've gotten the call that warning
seven date you will die in seven days
and they know enough to know that this
is the supernatural thing and it's a
curse and so when you're dealing with
something that weird who you're going to
call so that that's that's that's where
we start
so we've got the ghostbusters
investigating the ring the rain and
occur and the curse of it and all this
eventually you will have I think it's
Samara is her name in the US version
facing off against the Ghostbusters but
right he had the point where she's come
out of whatever screen she's come out
she's brandishing something no one's
ever seen before he's brandishing a book
and the book that looks like it's made
out of human flail Josh at which point
she takes she gets a shotgun to the road
was just entered nicely spinning around
and you whip the camera back you hear
groovy and so we can we have evil daddy
Ghostbusters versus the ring ash and the
Ghostbusters together that would be
ibid down for them versus anything I
throw my bike up against Cthulhu bra
like a sacred versus the girl from the
ring I like that oh oh yeah I like so
this is awesome okay I want to see that
too so I mean these sorts of things are
fun and the thing is as ridiculous as 1d
sound if you actually think about some
of the ones that have been done or came
close to happening these aren't as
ridiculous as they seem it really is
just a matter of when the reich's
resides at the same place I mean how
close did we come to 21 Jump Street
crossing over with men and black they
were they were actually gonna do that
which doesn't matter good fun I don't
know honestly it might have been I mean
that Heidi and I would even go so far as
to say 20 versions Jason was fun I think
it is okay I just thought okay I just
thought of Michael Myers from Halloween
yes
goes to Halloween Town from The
Nightmare Before Christmas
the movie will last six minutes I that
would that would be that would be a
supporting feature I think that's going
to be like a Robot Chicken bit I don't
know yeah that's not exactly okay
there's got to be some creepy animated
Pegasus none of them there aren't any
babysitter's or kids in the
Halloweentown they're all well actually
sure that sure there are but they're
lock stock and barrel who are who are
gotta give the knife minors a much
bigger run for his money than he's used
to hilarious thing yeah that actually
turns things around he's [ __ ] Sally
and somebody some levels of other will
be Bowie plays with pasta Oh see he not
now we're now spinning now it's not just
a short anymore now now we now we've got
we've got maybe a half hour in an
anthology film now my combines was
actually hunted himself and tormented by
three annoying with opiate cool alright
that's something at least yeah it is
it's not nothing so I like I said both
this business was just a fun one that we
felt like talking together cuz you know
what sometimes it's just
not to have to look at the news of
what's actually happening and going why
does anyone think that's a good idea
but so that battle about this Orion plug
your project of choice I've got a number
of podcasts you can find them all on the
fire water podcast network of their one
iTunes the interwebs what have you and
you can also read my webcomic my pet
ninja available at Rising Sun comics com
can I get it on my Zune is there such a
thing there is somewhere around the
california eat space i love this if
someone's a great fit if you are
watching the video this you can listen
to an unedited version of this
conversation which actually depending on
how this probably ran shorter than we
usually do so i might just put the
unedited version up as a video i don't
even know but in case i didn't the
unedited version will be available as a
podcast the the council of geeks podcast
available on itunes and stitcher so
thanks so much for tuning in then you're
on and until next time this council is
adjourned
[Applause]